[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und schönen
guten Abend der Blick auf den Sport mit
Norbert Lehmann
in den USA legen sich die Republikaner
gerade gegenseitig Stein in den Weg
macht Kampf bei us-republikanern
Fraktion
bei der Wahl zum Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses weiter um eine
Mehrheit
Sorge für corona-welle die EU-Staaten
beraten über einheitliche Einreise
Regeln für Flug Passagiere aus China
und wir chancentournee in Innsbruck der
Pole David Kubatzki holt sich den
Tagessieg die Deutschen sind weit
abgeschlagen
es ist ein mächtiger Job wer den Vorsitz
im US-Repräsentantenhaus hat ist die
Nummer 3 im Staat nach Präsident und
Vizepräsidentin der Republikaner
McCarthy ist jetzt der erste Kandidat
seit 100 Jahren der nicht sofort zum
Vorsitzenden gewählt wurde und das liegt
an Teilen seiner eigenen Fraktion bei
den Zwischenwahlen am 8 November hatten
die Republikaner nur eine knappe
Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus gewonnen
mit 222 der 435 Abgeordneten aber wir
haben Kandidaten McCarthy verweigern
abtrünnige aus den eigenen Reihen
bislang die nötige Mehrheit ohne einen
gewählten Vorsitzenden kann diese Kammer
des US-Kongress weder ihre Arbeit
aufnehmen noch die neu gewählten
Abgeordneten vereidigen MRT Wissen mit
den Einzelheiten
das Schauspiels nächster Akt beginnt mit
dem Fahnen altminuten-lang lässt Kevin
McCarthy auf sich warten denn hinter den
Kulissen wird verhandelt dann geht es
doch noch los
mit ihm aber sein krachen des Scheitern
von gestern dreimal halt weiter nach
[Applaus]
kein Sprecher gewählt
kein anderer in Aussicht nach dem
Debakel fragen Sie ihn ob es denn
irgendwelche Umstände gibt unter denen
er aufgeben würde nein auf keinen Fall
wir sind ja nicht weit weg nur elf
Stimmen fehlen
sogar Donald Trump wirft sich in die
Bresche stimmt für Kevin er wird gute
Arbeit machen vielleicht sogar großartig
aber Appelle an die Vernunft und
Verantwortung der Abweichler Verhalten
auch schon gestern
wir müssen den Herausforderungen gerecht
werden für die das amerikanische Volk
uns alle nicht nur Republikaner oder
Demokraten hierher geschickt hat
trotzdem wollen die radikalen in der
Partei auch heute auf keinen Fall
aufgeben
ich will die Werkzeuge und die Anführer
um diesen Sumpf davon abzuhalten die
Amerikaner jeden Tag zu betrügen
Hardliner mit gets schickte sogar einen
Brief an die Verwaltung des
kapitolgebäudes McCarthy habe kein
Anrecht auf das sprecherbüro in das er
schon eingezogen war
und jetzt erhöhen die Abweichler den
Druck sie nominieren Byron Donalds er
wäre wenn gewählt der erste schwarze
Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses
und jetzt ist uns elmative sind
zugeschaltet Elmar hinter den Kulissen
ringt die Fraktion der Republikaner
derzeit um eine Einigung wie könnte die
aussehen
ja es hat über Nacht offenbar
Verhandlungen gegeben und man plante
sogar die Sitzung heute zu verschieben
weil man noch mehr Zeit für die
Verhandlungen haben wollte aber die
Forderungen waren so extrem ganz
offenbar von den radikalen sie wollen
einerseits wichtige Posten in wichtigen
Ausschüssen des Parlaments haben sie
wollen zum zweiten jederzeit das Recht
haben Anhänger an Gesetzentwürfe
anzuhängen ohne dass der Sprecher des
Hauses also dann auch ihr Chef zustimmen
müsste und sie wollen jederzeit dass
jeder einzelne Abgeordnete ein
Misstrauensvotum einbringen kann um den
Sprecher des Hauses mit einer Mehrheit
dann natürlich zu stürzen das sind
Forderungen auf die mehr Kaffee nicht
eingeht deswegen ist es jetzt im vierten
Wahlgang und es sieht alles danach aus
als würde mehr Kaffee wieder scheitern
also wir müssen uns auch weitere
Wahlgänge und vielleicht eine lange
Wartezeit einrichten danke für diese
Einschätzung MRT wissen
nach dem ukrainischen artillerieangriffe
auf die russische militärunterkunft in
mackiewka hat Moskau die Zahl der Opfer
nach oben korrigiert nicht 63 sondern 89
russische Soldaten sein ums Leben
gekommen
Schultern im Angriff sei die leichte
Ortung durch die massenhafte Nutzung von
Mobiltelefon russischer Soldaten gewesen
so ein Militärsprecher obwohl das im
Reichweite feindlicher Waffen streng
verboten sei die Ukraine geht von bis zu
400 Toten bei dem Angriff in der
Silvester Nacht aus
für veganen Moskau gibt es nach diesem
ukrainischen Angriff mit den vielen
getöteten russischen Soldaten denn jetzt
Kritik an der russischen Militärführung
erstmal muss man vielleicht sagen dass
es absolut ungewöhnlich ist dass das
russische Militär überhaupt über
Rückschläge spricht und auch Fehler in
den eigenen Reihen eingesteht aber ganz
typisch wiederum ist dass diese
Selbstkritik genauso wie auch die Kritik
die zum Beispiel von militärbloggern
politischen Figuren und so weiter kommt
auf den unteren Rängen hängen bleibt und
eben nicht die Militärführung selbst
erreicht eine Ausnahme bildet da
Igor gierkin der führte schon 2014 pro
russische Separatisten an und wird per
internationalen Haftbefehl gesucht der
schrieb sinngemäß das unter Scheu gun
niemand der ehrlich sei im
Verteidigungsministerium arbeiten können
keine Silbe zu den vielen toten Soldaten
kein Funken der Anteilnahme gab es heute
von Wladimir Putin stattdessen markige
Worte als er ein neues Hyperschall
Waffensystem in den Dienst stellte der
russische Präsident will nicht mit den
Rückschlägen seines Militärs assoziiert
werden stattdessen weiter als der starke
Anführer da stehen und an diesem Image
wird derzeit weder aus der russischen
bevölker noch von den Eliten hörbar
gekratzt Dankeschön für Bagger
frankreich will der Ukraine sogenannte
leichte Kampfpanzer des Typs AMX 10rc
liefern das Herr Präsident macron dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
zugesagt wie viele Panzer Frankreich zur
Verfügung stellen will und wann sie in
der Ukraine ankommen sollen ist noch
unklar
mehr als ein Viertel aller
Rüstungsexporte die im vergangenen Jahr
in Deutschland genehmigt wurden gehen an
die Ukraine das gab das
Wirtschaftsministerium bekannt insgesamt
erlaubte das Ministerium Exporte im Wert
von 8,36 Milliarden Euro das ist etwas
weniger als der Rekordwert von 2021 nach
der Ukraine kommen die Niederlande die
USA und Großbritannien etwa 90% der
deutschen Rüstungsgüter gingen an enge
Partnerstaaten hieß es in Berlin
vor kurzem waren ja 18 Schützenpanzer
Puma bei einer bundeswehrübung
ausgefallen bei der Reparatur seien
überwiegend kleinere und mittlere
Schäden festgestellt worden teilte jetzt
das Verteidigungsministerium mit der
Kauf weiterer Puma des Herstellers
Rheinmetall ist seit den Pannen
ausgesetzt wie es um den Schützenpanzer
bestellt ist berichtet Ines Trams
17 der 18 defekten Schützenpanzer Puma
sind wieder fit nun liegt ein erster
Schadensbericht vor der heute ans
Parlament ging der Befund zeige ein
differenziertes Bild überwiegend kleiner
und mittlerer aber auch einzelner
schwerwiegender Schäden auch
vermeintlich einfache Ausfälle können im
Gefecht zum Tode führen deswegen muss
das sorgfältig untersucht werden und das
tun wir der gravierendste Schaden ein
Kabelbrand einige Schäden sind aber wohl
auf einfache Bedienfehler zurückzuführen
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht hatte
nach dem Ausfall der Panzer Nachrüstung
und Nachkauf weiterer Puma ausgesetzt
die Ministerin lag komplett falsch mit
ihrer Ersteinschätzung bei der sie die
Industrie für die Mängel
hauptverantwortlich gemacht hat der
Gegenteil ist der Fall dieses blaming
gegenseitig das ist die Industrie oder
das sind die Soldaten die damit nicht
umgehen können das bringt uns ja nicht
weiter nach der Fehleranalyse soll der
Puma nun nochmals nachgebessert werden
klar ist jedoch ohne Beistand von
industrietechnikern kann der anfällige
hochkomplexe Puma nicht in den Einsatz
gehen
hier haben wir eine große
Herausforderung wo man sich fragt warum
die vorher nicht gesehen worden ist
unter dem Bedingungen von Landes und
Bündnis Verteidigung ziviles privates
Personal in den Einsatz zu schicken
scheint nicht ganz realitätskonform zu
sein ein spitzen Treffen von
industrietruppe und Ministerium soll nun
klären wie gefechtstauglich also
kriegstauglich der Puma tatsächlich ist
wegen der aktuellen corona-welle in
China beraten die EU-Staaten zur Stunde
darüber ob und wie sie Reisende von dort
kontrollieren wollen das zielgespräche
in Brüssel ein gemeinsames Vorgehen
bisher haben einzelne mitgliedsländeramt
wie Frankreich Italien und Spanien ihre
Einreise Regeln eigenständig verschärft
laut EU-Kommission ist eine Mehrheit für
corona-test vor dem Abflug in Richtung
EU
es wird also wohl eine testpflicht geben
Isabel Schäfers in Brüssel wonach sieht
das aus worauf wird man sich noch
einigen
ja also diese Sitzung hier die dauert
länger als geplant und das zeigt wohl
auch den Druck den hier die meisten
empfinden sich hier politisch europäisch
einig zu zeigen zu Präsenz sind dann
noch die Lehren aus dem Beginn der
corona-pandemie als es ja ein
Flickenteppich aus nationalen allein
Gängen gab deswegen ist auch der Drang
hier groß sich jetzt auf zumindest ein
paar kleine Maßnahmen zu einigen und
darunter könnte zum Beispiel sein die
Empfehlung Masken zu tragen auf Flügen
aus China oder auch die Abwässer aus
diesen Flugzeugen zu kontrollieren
außerdem könnte man die Sequenzierung
von corona-test vorantreiben diese
testpflicht für Einreisende aus China
ist umstrittene da sind ja einige
Staaten bereits alleine vorangegangen
andere Staaten wie auch zum Beispiel
Deutschland sind da wesentlich
skeptischer aber auch hier gibt es jetzt
wohl eine Mehrheit und das zeigt auch
diesen politischen Druck hier europäisch
einig zu handeln was diese Maßnahmen am
Ende wirklich bringen werden das hängt
ja auch von der tatsächlichen
epidemiologischen Lage am Ende ab was
man aber sagen kann ist das Maßnahmen
die jetzt hier heute auf die man sich
hier heute einigen kann dann auch sofort
umgesetzt werden könnten vielen Dank für
diese Einordnung Elisabeth Isabel
Schäfers
nach den Angriffen auf Einsatzkräfte in
der Silvesternacht hat Berlins
Regierende Bürgermeisterin Giffey einen
Gipfel gegen Jugendgewalt angekündigt im
ZDF sprach sie sich außerdem für eine
schnelle Bestrafung der mutmaßlichen
Täter aus an Silvester hatten vor allem
junge Männer Polizei Feuerwehr und
Sanitäter in Berlin und anderen
Großstädten attackiert in der Hauptstadt
ist laut Giffey deshalb vor allem die
Jugend Sozialarbeit gefordert
Einsatzkräfte sollen zudem mehr
sogenannte bodycams erhalten
[Applaus]
unter der Inflation nicht nur die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sondern auch die
Kommunen sie müssen vieles Einkaufen
Handwerkerinnen beauftragen personalent
lohnen all das wird teurer Energie
sowieso und hinzu kommen noch
zusätzliche Kosten etwa für die
Unterbringung der geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine mehr Hilfe vom Bund forderten
sie heute Dominik Müller berichtet
Krefeld in Nordrhein-Westfalen eine
viertel Milliarde Euro als Schulden
Lasten auf der Stadt doch immer mehr
Ausgaben müssen sie zurzeit stemmen etwa
um Flüchtlinge unterzubringen oder
umgestiegene Energie und Personalkosten
zu bezahlen mit 50 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich zum normalen Budget rechnen
Sie hier wir müssen für gute Schulen
gute Kitas sorgen die ganze Sozial- und
Bildungsinfrastruktur aufrechterhalten
an der Thun 50 Millionen Euro wenn wir
nicht eins Erstattung vom Bund und Land
bekommen Kinder schon weh der Bund
beziehungsweise die Länder müssten
einspringen denn sie bürdeten den
Kommunen immer mehr auf argumentiert
auch der Städte und Gemeindebund der
soziale Frieden sei vor Ort in Gefahr
wenn die Kosten nicht übernommen würden
bei der Bewältigung der vielfältigen
Flugbewegungen sind wir und ich wage das
offen zu behaupten und die Grenzen unser
Leistungsfähigkeit angekommen die
drohende gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz
oder die gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz
droht gefährdet zu werden vor allem den
Armen überschuldeten Kommunen muss
geholfen werden denn sie leiden auch am
meisten unter den steigenden Kosten
plädieren Experten ich denke schon dass
die Ausgabenseite uns ein Stück aus dem
Ruder laufen wird ja und wenn wir die
Quantitäten kennen dann kann man
überlegen Länder und gegebenenfalls Bund
stützt man noch mal ab wie zu Beginn der
corona-krise damit die Städte ihren
Aufgaben weiter nachkommen können wenn
auch für sie alles teurer wird
in Deutschland sind 2022 wieder etwas
mehr Autos zugelassen worden zuvor war
der Absatz zwei Jahren Folge
zurückgegangen wie das
Kraftfahrtbundesamt mitteilte kam 2,65
Millionen Neuwagen auf die Straße
1,1% mehr als vorjahresfrist der Zuwachs
ist demnach einem Schlusssprint im
Dezember zu verdanken mit einem Fluss
von 38 Prozent vor allem
Elektrofahrzeuge legten 2022 zu 31
Prozent aller Neuzulassungen waren rein
elektrisch oder Plug-in-Hybride
das Comeback von Kohle und Öl
durchkreuzt die deutschen Klimaziele so
Berechnung der Denkfabrik agora
Energiewende zwar sei der
Energieverbrauch 2022 wegen des wilden
Klimas und hoher Preise um 4,7%
zurückgegangen und der Anteil
erneuerbarer Energien am Stromverbrauch
auf ein Rekordhoch von 46% gestiegen
doch mit 761 Millionen Tonnen
Treibhausgasen sei fast genauso viel
ausgestoßen worden wie im Vorjahr
insbesondere die Bereiche Verkehr und
Gebäude hätten ihre Klimaziele erneut
verpasst
was konkret bei den Emissionen alles
schief ging und was Fachleute jetzt
fordern das können Sie auf unserer ZDF
heute App nachlesen dort finden Sie auch
die konkreten Zahlen in welchen
Bereichen genau wie viel eingespart oder
zu viel verbraucht wurde
um die Klimaziele zu erreichen müssen
Wohnhäuser also mit deutlich weniger
energieauskommen und das heißt dämmen
und Sanieren was teuer ist für alle die
vermieten soll es trotzdem Sinn machen
zu investieren denn sie müssen sich
jetzt an der CO2-Abgabe beteiligen die
haben bisher allein die Mieterinnen und
Mieter bezahlt die mit Gas Öl oder
Fernwärme heizen wie das funktionieren
soll zeigt Goldmann
wer mit gasheizt zahlt derzeit eine
CO2-Abgabe von 0,6 Cent für jede
Kilowattstunde jedes Jahr können so
zwischen 50 und 200 Euro zusammenkommen
bisher zahlten das nur die Mieter mit
einem Stufenmodell sondern Vermieter
jetzt stärker zur Kasse gebeten werden
bei Gebäuden mit geringem CO2-Ausstoß
müssen die Mieter 100% der Abgabe selber
zahlen hier links in blau stößt ein
Gebäude mehr CO2 aus reduziert sich der
Anteil der Mieter bis hinunter auf 5%
entsprechend größer wird dann der Anteil
der Vermieter in orange
es kommt dabei aber nicht auf die Anzahl
der Bewohner an oder darauf ob das
Gebäude gut gedämmt ist oder nicht
sondern einzig und allein auf den
Verbrauch den könnten Vermieter aber gar
nicht beeinflussen kritisierte
eigentümerverband Haus und Grund
angeknüpft wird anders Heizverhalten und
das duschverhalten der Mieterinnen und
Mieter das ist höchst ungerecht sowohl
für Vermieter als auch Vermieter und
deswegen ist das Gesetz in der Form
wahrscheinlich auch verfassungswidrig
kritik kommt auch vom Deutschen
Mieterbund der sanierungsanreiz für
Vermieter sei viel zu gering bei relativ
niedrigem CO2-Preis aber vergleichsweise
deutlich höheren Investitionskosten das
Gesetz müsste deshalb dringend
nachgebessert werden das ist deswegen
der Fall weil es sich nicht um wirklich
viel Geld handelt bei diesem CO2-Preis
und in der derzeitigen Situation wird
garantiert niemand durch diesen
CO2-Preis dazu angereizt irgendwie in
effizienteres Heizsystem einzubauen
zudem bestehe die Gefahr dass das Wohnen
immer teurer wird weil Vermieter die
Sanierungskosten teilweise auf die Miete
umlegen können mit solchen Online-Tools
kann man jetzt schon ausrechnen wie die
CO2-Abgabe künftig aufgeteilt wird das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium will bis
Juni ebenfalls eine Berechnungshilfe
bereitstellen Klarheit wird es aber erst
geben wenn die Heizkostenabrechnung für
2023 auf dem Tisch liegt
kommen wir zur Vierschanzentournee
Norbert mit ja inzwischen etwas Flüge
lang DSV-Adler kein einziger deutscher
Springer bei der dritten Station in
Innsbruck in den Top Ten Philipp Reim
und immerhin 13 Karl Geiger ja erst gar
nicht mal qualifiziert dafür ein
spannender Zweikampf am Berg Esel
zwischen dem Norweger Halver Ätna
granold und dem Polen David
steht vor seinem zweiten Sprung unter
Druck der Gesamtführende der
Vierschanzentournee liegt nach dem
ersten Durchgang nur auf Rang 6 und
braucht einen richtig guten Sprung und
der gelingt ihm mit 133 Metern fliegt er
heute mit Abstand am weitesten doch für
den Sieg reicht es nicht den holt sich
der Pole David Kubatzki dem führenden
nach dem ersten Durchgang reichen bei
schlechteren Windbedingungen
121,5 m zum Tageserfolg im gesamtglasmo
ist Kubatzki trotzdem weiter deutlich
hintergründet vor dem Finale in
Bischofshofen ist der Norweger der große
Favorit auf den Sieg dieser
Vierschanzentournee bester Deutscher im
gesamtklassner ist Andreas Wellinger auf
Rang 8
bei der Tour des schien Oberstdorf
reicht es heute für Langläuferin
Katharina Hennig beim 20 Kilometer
Freistil Verfolgungsrennen nur für den 9
Platz Siegerin erneut die Schwedin Frida
Carson ja zur Darts WM in London der
neue Weltmeister heißt Michael Smith der
hat ja auch schon in deutschen
Shootingstar Gabriel Clemens aus dem
Turnier geworfen gestern Abend ein
hochklassiges Finale der Engländer
gewann gegen Michael van Gerwen aus den
Niederlanden mit 7:4
mit 32 Jahren ist Michael Smith am Ziel
seiner Träume mit einer Weltklasse
Leistung im Finale
ich bin durch so viele Tiefen gegangen
und jetzt habe ich sie endlich in Händen
die Trophäe in einem hochklassigen
WM-Finale in dem auch Gegner Michael van
Gerwen im zweiten Satz 8 perfekte Darts
spielte gelang Smith ein seltenes
Kunststück in der finalgeschichte der
Darts WM ein neuen data also ein
perfektes Spiel die Massen im Londoner
Ali Pelly elektrisiert mit sieben zu
viel gewandt mit seinen ersten WM-Titel
500.000 Pfund Preisgeld und führt nun
auch die Weltrangliste an
ja von Geld will sich Bully Boy so wird
er genannten echten Bullen kaufen für
den Vorgarten
aber sehr kleiner Bulle dann
wahrscheinlich
bleiben wir bei den Tieren und einer
rühren Geschichte nicht nur für die
Menschen in Köln denn der dortige Zoo
hat geerbt und wie ganze 26 Millionen
Dollar kann an den nächsten Jahren in
neue Tieranlagen stecken so hat es die
Verstorbene US-Amerikanerin Elisabeth
Reichert sehr zur Freude des
zuschauerstandes bestimmt aus gutem
Grund die gebürtige Kölnerin und der
jüdischer Mann waren unter den Nazis von
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürgern versteckt
worden später in Amerika mit einem zu
Großhandel reich geworden entschied sie
Erbe soll den Kölner und den Tieren
Freude machen
und wir bleiben beim großen Geld hier
noch die Lottozahlen die Gewinnzahlen
lauten 19 29 31 34 37 57 Superzahl ist
die 0 weiter Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
das ungemütliche und zu milde Wetter
setzt sich fort mehr dazu gleich von es
sind Herrli das heute journal läuft um
21:45
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen das windige Regenwetter setzt
sich weiter fort erst einmal haben wir
es noch mit diesem Sturmtief hier zu tun
das bringt vor allem in der Nacht und
morgen noch viel Wind das verlagert sich
allmählich ostwärts aber das nächste
Tief kommt schon von Westen heran in der
Nacht also viele Wolken Regen und
durchaus auch mal Sturmböen bis ins
Flachland generell ziemlich windig die
Temperaturen dazu bis 4 Grad am
Alpenrand und 11 Grad im Südwesten
Deutschlands es ist generell recht mild
in der kommenden Nacht morgen dann
weitere kräftige Schauer im Osten
Deutschlands und starker Wind teils
stürmisch auch mal Sturm würden Wissens
Flachland das ganze verabschiedet sich
allmählich ostwärts und auch im Süden
kann es Schauern dazwischen gibt es mal
auf Lockerungen bevor dann zum Abend
neuer Regen aufkommt zu bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 8 Grad ganz im Norden
und 14 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands
ziemlich nett die nächsten Tage gehen
erstmal mit weiter und auch immer wieder
mit Regen der bezieht sechs bis 14 am
Freitag ein wenig kühler dann zum
Sonntag bei 5 bis 11 Grad damit ein
schöner Abend